les vacances de Gill verd dans un
instant pour ceux qui ont un petit
moral allez-y molo hein voilà c'est pas
à mettre entre toutes les mains les
vacances de Gill Verdet je vous le dis
les Chéries et dans un instant vous
allez accueillir un premier nouveau
allez voir il y a quatre nouveaux on a
déjà pris du retard parce que
normalement là à 18h35 c'était les 12
coups les 12 coups de lacu apparemment
on va en faire que deux coup ça continue
bon bonsoir qu'est-ce qu'il veut alors à
l'allée j'ai perdu mes bagages à
l'aéroport dorly qui arrive je partais
en Grèce ouais mais vu tes fringues
frère voilà le mec qui les a trouvé à
mon avis c'est bon il va te les rendre
j'arrive à rode évidemment au milieu des
grands incendies je suis pris au milieu
des incendies ah ouais le vol de retour
est annulé je peux pas rentrer ah oua et
quand j'arrive à revenir à Paris je dis
on oublie tout je prends la voiture je
descends dans le sud ou arrivé au nord
de Lyon ouais la nuit avec les enfants
sur l'autoroute sous le déluge la
voiture me lâche complètement TR quoi
même la voiture vous lâche trois
injecteurs en plein milieu de
l'autoroute trois injecteurs plus de
voiture et tout ça mais non j'ai dit au
f là c'est terrible et et les gens je
suppose que quand les gens te
reconnaissaient qui savaient t tempanes
les gens s'arrêtai et t'insulter alors
sur l' d'autoroute j'ai demandé à des
gens de m'aider les gens ont dit mais
démerdez-vous on s'en fout totalement et
ce on est resté la nuit sur je dis bravo
les gens je dis bravo les gens bravo
bravo voilà si d'ailleurs il y a une
personne qui a croagé Gilles Verdet sur
l'autorout et qui lui a dit va te faire
[__] n'hésitez pas à venir témoigner
dans cette
émission la porte vous est ouverte bien
entendu hein oui un cauchemar un
cauchemar bah c'est l'histoire de ta vie
ex sinon ça va avec Fatou ça va très
bien elle était pas là non elle était
pas là pour tout ça mais on s'est
retrouvé elle a passé combien de temps
avec toi jours 8 jours donc sur 2 mois
elle a passé 8 jours avec toi absolument
et c'était les plus beaux jours tu te
poses les bonnes
questions non mais c'est pour savoir
parce que quand même toi tu as une meuf
ça fait quand même je sais pas combien
d'années qu'il est avec elle la meuf
passe 8 jours avec toi sur de mois et
demi de vacances à un moment tu te dis
pas il y a une couille dans le potage
elle m'a dit finalement c'est un bon
système 8 jours ensemble donc elle était
où j elle était pas était Mo je demande
pas sa vie sû pas parti avec un pote
avec ma voiture en
Portugal non mais ça va et le mariage
toujours pas ça avance doucement elle
vous ça fait 6 ans ça avance arrête un
peu tu seras mort avant de te marier
frère elle nous regarde elle m'a dit de
vous embrasser ah merci je l'adore elle
est née en 23 septembre ouais non enfin
presque 10 jours près mais c'est pareil
elle est donc née elle est donc née en
septembreou je t'embrasse je t'oublierai
jamais et merci
hein merci pourquoi de quoi de quoi elle
comprend
merci allez on passe
à CH maill comment allez-vous ben ça va
très bien moi je suis un peu gêné de
raconter mes vacances à côté du calvaire
de Gill Verdez moi ça s'est plutôt bien
passé bah c'est pas grave c TPMP je l'ai
dit sur France
ouais a des G qui on de la chance et a
des g il a des
gens voilà oui alors vous facile plutôt
fluide ouais Italie et Vegas j'adore
l'Italie vous l'année dernière l'année
dernière je suis parti en Italie j'ai
adoré quoi j'ai fait la Costa del Sol ah
ouis la Costa del Sol cétait incroyable
ils sont d'une gentillesse les
tortillasses tout ça il me faisait des
tortill moi j'étais plus sur la côte
ligure vous voyez genre s Réo
bordiguerra
ouais S c'est à côté de Nice vous êtes
pas loin de Nice s Mo non je suis allé
je suis crémon
[Rires]
[Applaudissements]
moiisis et en revanche à Vegas beaucoup
de gens on parl de vous non c'est vrai
sais j'ai un fort suc par donc là-bas
championnat du monde de poker donc c'est
un truc très très important il y a des
gens du monde entier qui viennent jouer
des grosses parties de poker et tous les
Français me disent mais alors cy il joue
plus au poker avant un gros joueur de
poker et comment ça se fait qu'il
viennent pas vraiment j'ai perdu mon
slip et vous qui êtes un homme de défi
vous dites je va absolument être dans le
top 100 peut-être pourquoi pas un bracel
un jour quoi commeou un truc je
reprendre je vais reprendre ça vous
irait bien je vais reprendre on ira
ensemble l'année prochaine avec plaisir
d'accord on amèa g ah ou cont on prend
pas l'AV
[Rires]
ensemblearz merci à tous d'être là vous
le savez d'ailleurs merci d'être là non
je vous le dis parce que vous savez que
le premier jour bien sûr c'est c'est
offert par la maison c'est
gratuit c'est de cadeau de bienv
exactement donc merci à vous de faire
cet effort mais normalement il un petit
cotail de bienvenu avec auss un petit
cocktail de bienvenu tu vas
voir tu vois tu veux prendre du chocolat
dans la gueule tu vois les gens on
t'inquiète pas c'est bon les chéris
allez je vous l'ai dit cet été j'étais
un petit peu le Nasser alhalafi du PAF
d'ailleurs j'embrasse Nasser ami que
j'adore et c'est vrai que voilà il y a
des grosses recrues cette émission on va
les accueillir une par une je sais que
vous les attendez on va leur demander
pourquoi elles sont venues qu'est-ce
qu'elles attendent de cette émission
pensent-elles qu'elles vont être payé
euh bien sûr et bien sûr la question que
tout le monde se pose comment vont-elles
s'en remettre euh pour le moment allez
je propose qu'on s'intéresse à cette
place là cette placel donc à côté de
Benaï et de Kelly et ouais et ouais
c'est la première fois je pense qu'il va
être aussi bien entouré ah oua parce que
c'est un reporter incroyable ah ah ouais
il a tout fait vous allez voir ça c'est
une grosse recrue on va vous dire
comment je l'ai recruté c'était le
présentateur de complément d'enquête
ouais sur France 2 il est avec nous ce
soir Jacques cardose nouvelle
[Applaudissements]
recrue
à
[Musique]
merci
merci merci merci merci pour merci merci
merci bonjour Jacques salut c bonjour
jaces cardose merci merci d'être là
merci à toi merci Jacques alors Jacques
cardose présente-toi un petit peu parce
que c'est un gros CV Jacques et on est
très très heureux que tu viennes on a
fait le pilote avec toi ça s'est très
bien passé tu as tapé fort lors du
pilote franchement même ch Verdez qui
aime pas les Nou ouais euh et ben là et
ben là je te le dis il a pris il a pris
un coup sur la j'ai bien fermé ma gueule
là Gill franchement tu t'as il t'as
impressionné ah il est bon il est bon il
est bon il parle bien il est concis ça
nous change vraiment des autres quoi
merci merci non c'est vrai c'est vra non
mais alors Jacques raconte-nous un peu
tu étais bon tu présentes t compléments
d'enquête mais d'abord il faut le dire c
c'est moi qui t'ai contacté c'est vrai
c'est vrai ah ça a été dit sur les
réseaux c'est un truc de fou c'est vrai
les gens ils me disent mais si si c'est
moi qui ai contacté cil il m'a laissé un
petit DM je regarde jamais je que c'est
vrai je regarde jamais mes DM et je ne
réponds pratiquement jamais euh message
privé sur Instagram exactement bien et
merci bravo c'est important et Jacques
m'a laissé un petit message je sais plus
tu me disais cyil est-ce que tu veux
qu'on prenne un petit ver ensembble
ouais je d vas-y banco on s'est vu 2
jours après on a pris un verre ensemble
un thé un thé glacé ouais c'est c'est un
thé glacé très bon d'ailleurs he ouais
excellent d'ailleurs ça m'a coûté une
ces conneries d'ailleurs aussi j'is
glacé je peux dire qu'il douillé là-bas
euh et donc et donc ensuite et ben on
s'est on s'est kiffé on a pris un verre
ensemble on s'est parlé on s'est appelé
derrière et tout de suite c'est vrai que
ça ça a pas traîné au bout de 5 minutes
je t'ai dis c'est bon c'est bon c'est
bon je t' dis c'est bon tu viens tu
viens moi ce que je trouve génial c'est
ta capacité à écouter le l'échange qu'on
peut avoir ici le débat ouais non parce
que on est dans une période où on donne
beaucoup de leçons la presse donne
beaucoup de leçons mais moi des
émissions où tu passes 2h3 à parler de
société à parler de différents sujets et
avec le le sourire si possible j'en
connais pas beaucoup et en plus tu le
fais avec beaucoup de gens et puis en
plus tu sais moi euh il y a quelque
chose que je supporte pas à la télé
c'est les donneurs de
leçonsis il y a la il y a la grande télé
celle qui est celle qui a une grande
réputation qui est respectueuse qui
n'est pas regardé et puis il y a l'autre
oui on dit c'est ce qu'on dit hein sur
la place de Paris mais moi j'aime pas ce
discours là pour moi tout le monde on
doit respecter tout le monde
et j'aime tout le monde et l'occasion tu
m'as offert cette occasion de pouvoir
être ici et de pouvoir parler de
débattre j'aime la contradiction donc je
suis très heureux d'être là merci à toi
on est très content de t'avoir avec nous
Jacques cardos qui fait
ton merci mon Jacques
allez il y
a il y a un deuxième trou ah oui ah benï
j'ai ri
dit insupportable regarder exprès
calme-toi tu vas sortir he bah oui un
deuxième trou à côté de Kelly euh c'est
une nouvelle recrue également il est là
e il a présenté combien il dit je crois
350 prime bon non 35 non non 3 et demi
euh il a présenté tris prime et demi sur
M6 non non non comment tu as présenté de
prime une centaine un peu plus d'une
centaine 200 200 [__] je savais pas
que c'était toi oui c'est Alex G est
avec
nous
[Applaudissements]
merci Alex Alex qui nous rejoint je suis
très très très heureux d'avoir Alex e
grand animateur Alex il a fait des
primes sur M6 on veut en voilà plus
d'une centaine plus une centaine sur Oui
c'est sympa ça me fait ça va frérot
c'est c'est pour moi comment ça va mon
Alex tout très content d'être là je suis
content de te voir aussi après un été de
fou je me suis affuté pour te pulvériser
j'ai vu ça ça r pas tu es boulanger ou
tu es vraiment habillé comme
[Applaudissements]
[Rires]
ça si tu veux je tu veux je te libère
avant pour faire des foues tu me dis moi
frère non mais quand on m'a dit ça c'est
pas sûr tu vas peut-être qu'en faire
qu'une et tout je mets toutes les
chances de mon côté comme je suis un peu
célibataire je me dis je vais peut-être
Gill ça va peut-être le tenter je alors
des trucs e pas mal alors c'est c'est la
première fois que quelqu'un attaque g
dès la première
émission non c'est amusant parce que
c'est vrai que souvent il me rentre un
peu dedans au sens évidemment end to tu
fais ce que tu veux figurer du terme
mais du coup maintenant je suis ravi de
l' voir en face de moi car nous pourrons
débattre exactement é es content de de
le voir quand même mais mais je je le
trouve de plus en plus beau c'est le
colosse de Rod je sais qu'il est là-bas
mon silence mais ça marche pas avec
j'essa quand même tu vois j'essae des
trucs c'est plutôt la brindie de Rod
franchement Alex en tout cas je suis
très heureux de te voir je suis très
heureux que tu nous rejoignes qu'est-ce
qui t'a fait venir raconte parce qu'on
aime bien quand avec JAC on a raconté
comment comment comment il est arrivé
toi s fait dans ma loge ça c'est fait
dans ta
le il
évolué il y avait lonel stade directeur
général moi je mange pas
mec je suis pas voilà c'est bon c'est
bon non mais oui oui il y a pas de mal
non il y a pas de mal non il y a pas de
mal non il y a pas de mal trou oui bah
non mais c'est bon alle vous êtes libre
oui ben vous me cassez les couilles oui
oui donc la vérité c'est que c'est vrai
que je j'avais arrêté la télé pas
forcément de mon plein gré mais en tout
cas c'était le cas et j'étais parti vers
le cinéma pour faire des films et puis
tu m'as rappelé et tu m'as demandé de
venir te voir et et de me dire bah
pourquoi pas qu tu la télé je me suis
dit bah quand c'est toi qui propose é tu
es tellement convaincant je pense tu es
meilleur vendeur que j'ai vu de ma vie
je me suis dit voilà je me suis dit ok
tu as raison je vais m'amuser avec toi
et je vais venir voilà
heureux on s'estéclaté sur le pilote
exactement moi je suis très content qu'
a Alex et c'est vrai que c'est une
expérience énorme Alex et il a été je
vous dis quand je suis sorti du pilote
je j vrai j'ai dit vous avez vu voyez
c'est un métier j'ai d c'est un métier
Alex il envoie tout de suite et c'est
vrai que tas envoyé tout de suite je
suis très heureux de te voir et tu
t'habilles comme tu veux ici ça me
touche beaucoup et je vais t'organiser
un petit four juste
derrière je suis nul en cuisine mais je
je vais apprendre si ça te fait plaisir
je te comment tu es célibataire qui
alors oui oui c'est ça je dis que pour
rester je vais essayer de Cré une
histoire avec avec quelqu'un ici ça
garantira ma place un petit suspect
alors si je peux te donner là j'ai peur
du
tobogan il y a quelqu'un qui cherche
actuellement si tu aimes les
camions si tu as les camions et les
maillots de
foot j'étais footballeur avant
donc les
gars est-ce qu'ils ont pas se tirer des
penalties ces deuxl là
cet été à la maison les deux vir en but
contre son camp j'aime bien j'aime bien
vous êtes content hein content oui oui
on s'est parlé d'ailleurs on a commencé
ch on rigole pas du tout Alex t'inquiète
pas tu es magnifique ça t'était rien
rien zé compliqué
compliqué c'est pour ça je me suis j'is
dans le j'étais dans le paddle le régime
ouais bon bah si tu veux jouer au paddle
tu m'appelles B c'est le but en fait le
si tu veux Péchot appell-m voilà merci
mon chéri voilà je te dis alle il reste
deux places allez on va accueillir on va
accueillir ah bah on va accueillir celui
qui à côté vous plus c'est votre pote
c'est un pote à vous et c'est vrai qu'on
l'aime beaucoup ça fait longtemps que je
l'ai dans le nez ça fait longtemps que
je veux le le recruter et cette année
était la bonne mundir est avec
[Applaudissements]
nous est avec nous c'est son
anniversaire
[Applaudissements]
avec nous merci mon e tu sens très bon
toi ah bah oui ah non mais je te le jure
là j'ai eu un attention ouais un crus tu
m'as déstabilisé non mais je te dire
hfactivement on s s plomb nous
non j'ai pas vou le dire mais oui oui
oui en tout cas oui ça vous a saisi ah
ça m'a saisi e je sens bon tu as coupé
tes cheveux oui ça tu veux je dis ça te
va hyper bien parce que moi on il y a un
pote qui m'a dit mundir sans les cheveux
c'est comme Raymon sans son camion et
ben je dis ben je ne suis pas d'accord
je ne suis pas d'accord ça te va hyper
bien mon chéri ben c'est gentil ouais je
repositionne tout mon age sur sur le
capillaire ouais c'est très beau comme
ça voilà et puis aussi je suis grand fan
de champoing c'est vrai voilà ou tu n en
parleras plus tard parce que là on va
comment ça va et je suis très content de
te voir je sais pas moi c'est moi je le
voulais depuis des années donc mes
équipes m'ont même pas demander en fait
quand il y a un mec que je depuis des
années il l'appelle euxmême il disent
bon voilà c'est et donc ils m'ont appelé
un G ils m'ont dit c'est bon mundir a
dit oui et qu'est-ce qu'il faisait qu'il
pouvait pas venir bah il il animé sur W9
il avait plein de trucs et puis après il
bah c'était il était sur W9 en fait et
un moment voilà ouais ouais c'est
surtout que je voulais quand il était
quand il faisait l'émission quand il
était animateur je le trouvais très bon
je lui laissais souvent des messages
dire tu es excellent il faisait des
scores incroyables d'ailleurs il était
en face de nous il me faisait chier
absolument sur c'est surtout moi qui
arrivit à surviv un petit peu non non
c'est vrai et et et quand mes équipes
m'ont dit c'est bon mundir nous rejoint
j'étais très très heureux et je suis
très VO parce que tu es un pote en plus
on va rigoler et en plus il a un très
très bon avis sur la il a un avis sur
tout et c'est ça qui m'intéressa aussi
ben merci en tout cas de de me faire
confiance en tout cas plus à côté de ta
pote
absolumentra tu vois toi toi moi
j'ai c'est voilà ou
dis-moi avait contrôle
d'histoire
s déconner
[Applaudissements]
frérot il a ramené des passeports pour
la 4e ou quoi e dis-moi e on lui a volé
[Rires]
son ah c'est
extraordinaire ça je lu attendais pas
elle est arrivé espér j'ai vu oh [__]
j'embrasse Daniel en tout cas mais la
photo est folle meilleure photo
meilleure photo du monde sans déconner
on dirait des gars qui m chez le grand
frère sur la tête de ma mère on dirait
des AD
difficiles mais sur la tête de ma mère
extraordinaire bravo bravo bravo ça ce
qu'tiendra du
pilote ah non mer on a
l' allez les chér dernière recrue et al
celle-ci passer l'été avec elle l' est
la photo la photo est je la mets en fond
d'écran c'est sûr c'est mon fond
d'écran ça me rappelle la photo Mathieu
valbouen te rappell de Mathieu
Val a Mathieu très sympathique allez
c'est parti dernière recrue alors elle
elle a fait la matinale de BFM elle
était sur LCI elle est revenue à BFM et
alors là je peux vous dire j'en ai eu
des coups de fil jusqu'à 2h du matin des
trucs et j'ai réussi à la faire venir je
suis très très très heureux elle fera
l'émission juste avant nous d'ailleurs
qui s'appellera PAF à partir de demain
17h50 à ne pas manquer il y aura
Isabelle ma boss d'ailleurs dans PAF oui
oui oui je sais pas combien de temps
mais non non non
non isabelleos et Damien canivz et oui
les chér et oui ils ne sont pas morts
les revenant oui les revenants
exactement il
seront
c'est revenant S c'est Leonardo Di
Caprio les deux vir il voir
demain qu'est-ce que vous pensez
qu'est-ce que vous pensez du
remplacement de Nico dans 50
minutes c'est des revenants donc il a
des revenants voilà ça va être génial
vous inquiétez pas c'est PAF à 17h50 re
avec nous déjà Pascal de la je me suis
dit ça va s'arrêter là de la tour non ça
s'arrête pas
mais sans déconner j'ai cru qu' même du
P sur le balcon allez PASC de la tour
[Applaudissements]
[Musique]
du
voulez-vous merci pas d'êre a nous chéri
quel bonheur mais quel bonheur oh là là
bonhe et toi c'est pas que ta glow up ta
glow up ah
ouais tu es magnifique elle est si belle
chez nous parce que les
photos je texque es beaucoup plus belle
sur C que sur les autres chaînes excuse
moi te dire ça sur la tête de ma mère tu
es une bombe
[Rires]
atomique he rmon qu'elle est belle
Pascal c'est surtout la tour du pain le
le nom ouais déjà c'est trop pour toi
déjà PASC la tour du c'est pas possible
kiff déjà imagine ch Mar avec toi elle
va s'appeler Pascal Abou de la tour du
pain le Abou on comprend pas ce qu' là
je sors avec Pascal de la tour du pour
l'instant tu sors avec personne donc
merci donc tu ces s'il te plaît tu
redescends de étages merci tu es mignon
Pascal je suis tellement content de te
voir on est devenu très proche parce qu'
on est devenu très copain on s'est on
s'est vu cet été est venu me voir ah oui
ouais et on s'est beaucoup parlé je
croyais que j'allais partir en vacances
le 13 juillet puis tu m'as appelé je
t'as appelé quelle jour déjà le 13
juillet sor de l'émission crois pas
juillet 14 juillet le jour de la
dernière et tu m'appelles je tombe un
peu de de l'armoire tiens je l'appelle
je lu dis Pascal qu'est-ce que tu fais
l'année prochaine ouais c'est elle me
dit B j'ai un
travail j'en ai peut-être un cortois
également et elle me dit bah qu'est-ce
qu'on fait je dit bah tu viens me voir
demain ou après là tu es venu 2 jours
après 2 jours après ou oui je t' dis
faut qu'on se parle elle V voir à la
maison sorti le grand jeu
Benco
ben des Ben des dou des petits princes
des
granol au bout de 2 he elle avait
signé elle va nous dire comment comment
on a signé avec Pascal de Tup parce que
ça a été quand même un petit périple et
je suis tellement heureux que tu sois là
ma Pascal on va parler de Paf également
où bien sûr tu seras entouré de
chroniqueur également et demain Isabelle
mbosque et Damien ils on été super hein
je sais s'il passe la nuit euh bien
entendu on va se retrouver dans un
instant on va jouer dans un instant
également et Pascal tu nous disas on va
raconter on va raconter toute notre
histoire Pascal et on va jouer au 12
coups de lactu avec Jean-Luc rechman qui
sera avec nous dans un instant la
question
co alors il y en a c'est pas du tout ça
la question co c'est catastrophique
allez 19h2 je vous rappelle qu'on est en
directin ça a pas l'air comme ça parce
qu'ils ont l'air de mais on est en
direct je vous le dis ça ça passe tout
ce que vous dites ça passe d'accord
ouais tout le monde sait que oui il est
pas tout le monde sait
que sais depuis qu' Pascal frère on
dirait Johnny en
concert tu as perdu 8 kg tout de
suite